foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell Join This Hour by Jade warshaw
and we are elated to take your questions
today about money and life if you're at
a Crossroads you need some motivation
inspiration education we are here for
you America give us a call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five you ready to go Jade let's
do it all right Rose is joining us up
first in Detroit Rose welcome to the
show
hi thanks for having me absolutely how
can we help
uh so my question is
um my my boyfriend wants to sell both of
our cars and get a truck and I don't
think that's a good idea but he said
it's for our kids safety so
I was calling to see what you think I
saw you sell the boyfriend hey I'm
kidding I don't know George I wasn't
fully kidding don't you guys need two
cars like is he saying why is he why is
your boyfriend wanting to sell your car
well he has a van that he drives for for
work
um that's paid off his car is paid off I
still owe 13 000 on my car but he wants
to do it
um he wants to get a truck because he he
thinks it's it's best for the kids
safety and that he sits on a throne of
Lies he wants a truck because he's a
little kid inside who played with a big
truck when he was little uh-huh and he
wants a truck
is that fair that's what I think I think
that he really he wants safety he needs
to get himself a minivan
here's the question was he specific
about the truck that he wanted because
this is going to tell us a lot was he
specific
no not really no
the question still stands what is he
doing meddling with your finances yeah
good question
um what does this truck have to do with
your car is the big question
okay because so
I I drive my car my kids are with me
most of the time
and he tells me that
um you know for safety wise uh if we get
a car accident or anything like that he
thinks that having a truck is better
than having a Ford Escape so okay
um and then I still owe 13 000 on this
car which I know I could probably pay it
off by the end of this year and I want
to keep it until it's all paid off so
Rose you can do what you want to do girl
yeah you can do what you want to do and
you you what you want to do in my mind
is the best choice keep the car you have
and pay it off is there any reason like
logical reason because just a truck is
safer is is not a logical reason there's
plenty of cars on the road and didn't
you say a Ford Escape that's like a
mid-size SUV
yeah okay
um yeah what he's saying is bananas
don't do it what's your income I guess
I'm not bananas then no you're not you
are not okay good it's your car it's
your kids and until you're married and
sharing finances it's your money which
means it's your prerogative Rose are you
guys already have you guys combined
finances
not yet we are not married yet
um then he doesn't get a say in what you
do with your car if he wants to go get
himself a truck he can go get himself a
truck and let you use it sometimes
if that's if it's really that big idea
I told him I said if he wants to get a
truck then he can get it everything in
his name and I can drive it that's fine
with me that's right Rose you go tell
him that and how have a little bit of an
attitude when you say it
give him the tube Rose is this do you
feel like this car is unsafe
I don't think so
um I I honestly don't like I said I I
still owe money on it and I just want to
pay it off and and keep it because I
I'm tired of paying for for this car and
and I know I can pay it off by the end
of this year and by then I and it's in
2018 so it's newer okay a great car okay
what's your income yeah
uh well I I was a stay-at-home mom this
past year but I'm starting a new job
next week and I'll be making about 40
000 a year awesome any other debt that
you have
uh three thousand dollar on a credit
card that I'm working on paying it off
and then and then that's it that's great
so let's attack that credit card first
let's knock that out free up a payment
and then we'll attack that car loan and
I totally believe you'll have this thing
paid off by the end of the year
yeah absolutely um
okay can I just ask one quick question
sure um so both my kids have one
thousand dollars each
um that they got for birthdays and such
these past few years there's four and
six and I I don't know what to do with
it
I would just throw it into a 529
yeah okay just start putting it towards
yeah if it's if it's in if it's birthday
money or something like that I mean uh
that's why they have unless they have a
purchase they want to make a little
small if they're trying to buy a toy or
a video game and they want to save up
and use some of that that's okay but
it's it's a great opportunity to teach
them to give save and spend we're going
to give a little bit spend a little bit
and save a little bit George saving a
whole bunch they're gonna look back at
that money and go I'm so glad I actually
saved that because now I can go to
college debt free now I have some money
to throw at my first car so it's a great
uh lesson you can teach them at this age
you're doing so good as a mom
oh thank you um so do I start uh an
account separate for each or combined I
would just do you could do separate
accounts and make them the beneficiary
on that and uh that'll that'll help
separate it when it comes time for for
college and it'll be in their own name
they'll have some skin in the game and
they'll be excited looking that at that
account going oh that's for me to go to
college debt free thanks Mom all right
okay sounds great well thank you so much
for answering my questions uh that
really helped and uh you guys have a
good day thank you so much
what a sweet woman I love Rose she is
sweet she's so nice her boyfriend he was
tripping he he he saw a nice little Rose
I can't imagine if I told my wife hey
and we're married combined finances if I
was like hey honey you want to sell both
of our cars because I want a truck for
safety oh gosh I I don't know Whitney
very well but something tells me that
wouldn't go over well she's not taking
that I don't know what it is about guys
and trucks I think we raise the
generation of the kids playing with the
big Tonka trucks I mean they're nice we
love a truck maybe it makes us feel like
in control I mean Dave drives a big
truck and I don't want to be in his way
on the road a true I'll tell you that
much let me real talk we used to live in
South Florida I mean pickup trucks
aren't really a thing there everybody
wants like electric cars we moved here
and I started seeing like Dodge Rams on
the road and like f-350s and I was like
this is nice there something came out of
me even that I was like I don't mind
this and then make matters worse we were
a one-car family we needed a second car
so my dad's like hey you can borrow our
truck it's a F-150 I love getting in and
out of it even though it's super old
what is it it's rock and roll I don't
know man what else trucks are one of the
main reasons American males are in debt
I'll tell you that much I mean those
things are freaking expensive they are
and they'll happily go into giant
payments for it under the guise of
safety yeah yeah no you know what's safe
not owing anyone anything okay and
driving a reasonable used car which are
just as safe as your shiny new car which
could be a Ford Escape in Rose's case
there we go
you don't need to take it mudding you'll
be all right go with your buddies who's
in debt that's more fun oh my goodness I
love it more of your calls coming up
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show well we
had our Building Wealth live stream
event last Thursday night and we had
several hundred thousand of you tune in
and I know there was a lot of new people
who may have stumbled upon it someone
shared it with you it showed up on your
YouTube feed and so if you're a new
listener you're going what are they
talking about they're getting out of
debt in these baby steps what is this
thing and how do I get started well our
team created a free tool for you at
ramsaysolutions.com if you click on the
get started button you answer a few
simple questions and we will help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation we'll
give you some great tools and resources
and it's absolutely free go to
ramsaysolutions.com and click on the get
started button the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your more money Holly joins us
up next in San Antonio Holly welcome to
the show
hey thank you very much how are you guys
doing we're doing great how can we help
today
well um
to the point um 56 years old I just
entered into baby steps four five and
six and I have a very minimal retirement
meeting I just started last year I need
to understand how much I should put
towards my retirement versus paying off
my mortgage
very good question well you know it's
it's pretty simple in this case you know
we always want to follow the baby steps
in order so if you're on baby steps four
five and six you want to start with baby
step four which is investing the 15 so
are you currently investing any amount
right now
I am I um I have a I just started last
year but I fully funded the IRA last
year and I'm like 15 right now you're at
15 that's excellent so continue on with
that um is baby step five anything that
you need to think about sounds like no
okay no and then from there on we're
just being intentional intentional about
the mortgage so if you've got extra
money that you can throw towards that
now is the time to do that so it's about
being intentional for sure getting that
15 if you have extra money to throw out
the mortgage that's what you're going to
want to do from that point on and get
that mortgage paid off
how's that sit with you so my goal my
goal would be to pay off the mortgage
and then up my um contribution
percentages that's right how much is
left on the mortgage
um I still have about 220 000 left on
that okay and what's your income
about well
an extra 1200 months or 1200 a month
about eight months out of the Year oh
that's great so what is your what's your
gross salary for the year
um
doing math in my head right now I knew
you guys were going to make me do that
so my take-home uh gross is about 65 000
a year okay great so if we say that's
we're going to do 15 that's about 97.50
that's a little over 800 a month and you
said you're currently doing that through
maxing out your IRA as well as a 401k
what do you have for retirement I have I
have a I have a Roth and then I just
have a traditional IRA
okay you don't have any employer
retirement plan no no we don't have a
I'm a teacher and we just have our
pension and we there's no match or
anything like that okay so do you think
this pension is obviously alone it may
not give you the retirement you want but
do you have any idea of what that will
amount to in retirement
uh based on what I'm looking right now
the step I'm on if I retired at 65 that
would probably give me about 2 900 a
month okay and is your goal to have more
than that in retirement every month
yes it is great so there are other
options that you can look into to invest
in including a brokerage account outside
of retirement which means you're you're
going to have to pay taxes on that
there's no real tax advantages of this
but it can help your money grow between
now and 10 years from now
okay so if you don't have are you
working with a financial advisor
currently
I am yes okay do you like them you think
they're giving you good I love them yeah
good yeah that's good I've been working
on a plan with them to say hey am I
doing all the things I can do with this
money to maximize it and on top of that
having a paid for house decreases your
expenses so I would really be angling to
get that thing paid off by the time I
retire
okay and if you need to downsize to do
that is that something you would do in
the future
um it's it's not something that I would
just say no to okay you know obviously
my goal I love the home I'm in and it's
the perfect size for me and my dog so
you know I'd love to stay here love it
I'd definitely be aiming to pay that off
because then that 2900 even can go a lot
further if you don't have a mortgage
payment on top of that okay
so you're doing the right things I would
continue with the 15 and then pay off
the house once we get there we can
increase investing but that would be my
goal for the next you know several years
do you think you're going to retire in
the next five to seven years
I I'm I probably have about nine to 11
years left in me I think okay that's
great well would I'd love to retire
earlier sure but I'm not you know I love
what I do so what do you do you said
you're a teacher I am a teacher okay yes
work with your financial advisor have
them run out the projections and go hey
10 years from now let's with average
Returns what will my life look like
between the pension the IRA what I have
in savings what the mortgage will be
down to and start to base it off of that
instead of just hoping 10 years from now
you have a great retirement but you're
on the path Holly We are rooting for you
thanks for the call all right let's go
to Joshua up next in Atlanta Georgia
Joshua welcome to the show
all right hello guys
um how's everyone doing we are doing
great doing good what's going on with
you good good so I've got 45 so I bought
I purchased my home during that house
Rush um a couple years back
um I have about 40 to 50K in equity
right now of it but I also have a very
uh High student loan payment uh that
it's a private student loan for 31k and
it cost me about uh 700 a month to uh
you know to pay so things are kind of
tight right now but I think I could
still do it I also have a side job right
now okay
um and I was wondering if but the thing
with the side job is that it you know
that I can make anywhere between maybe
200 to
um 1200 a month but I mean it's it's not
um you know it's not very secure so I
was thinking of maybe selling the home
and um moving and renting for about
three years I figured if I put together
together a budget because I used to live
in Chicago
um and I figured day if I say for about
you know I can save about 12 Grand a
year
um what's in Chicago a couple years is
that family
uh yeah and uh and also a a job that I
used to work at there so
um so what's your current income
my current income is uh 70k a year okay
what's your total debt not including the
mortgage you got the 31k in student
loans what else uh all together it's
about
65.60 what other kind of debt do you
have
I have another federal student I have
another I have a Federalists do the
wrong debt and I have 3 600 a credit
card debt
okay
now how is moving to Chicago saving you
the 12 000.
because Chicago is expensive too
uh yeah but I just I um I could you know
I would have been there for a while back
when I was there I put together a budget
uh it was saving me because I wouldn't
have to eventually purchase a car and um
actually I wouldn't have to I wouldn't
have to purchase a car so you would sell
your pay you have a paid for car or does
that have a loan yeah yeah I have a pay
for a car and I wouldn't have to pay the
uh the stupid loan debt
because I would actually use uh the
equity to to pay off you know so you
sell the house you take the 40 50k in
equity and you pay down some debt
leaving you with another 25 of debt
my question is do you have to move
cross-country in order to sell a house
in a car or is it just that you want
that job in Chicago
well I mean that's it but it's also I
really wouldn't I I don't really use
public transport I mean I I use public
trans in Chicago so
um I really wouldn't need a I just want
to make sure that you're making the
choice based off of a long-term reason I
feel like wanting to use I feel like
selling a house selling a car moving
cross-country simply so you can use
public transit doesn't make I feel like
we're missing something George are we
missing something here no I mean I what
it feels like right now is you you think
you've got two options because you're
drowning in these payments and you're
going well if I move to Chicago this all
gets solved uh but the truth is you can
do this without absolutely needing to do
any of this and if you want to sell the
home to speed up this process because
you bought it at the wrong time and this
will help you can do that but I would
just rent in the area and yeah keep your
job don't uproot your life quite yet
because moving across country is
expensive yeah you make 70k with the
side jobs even more you can pay off
sixty five thousand dollars in two years
yes you can and so I would make that the
goal and of selling the house that's
something you want to do and you don't
need all the space I would go ahead and
sell that and use that Equity to pay off
that debt and speed up the process but
I'm not doing the cross-country move
quite yet that's a big jump my friend
thanks for the call this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell Join This Hour by Jade
warshaw and we are taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our question of the day comes from
Sarah in Virginia here's what Sarah's
asking I'm a 23 year old that graduated
college in May of 2022 and I got a job
at a non-profit making 45k a year I live
with my parents and plan on staying
there until I can buy a home I have no
debt no bills and have an inheritance of
75 000 sitting in a savings account
doing nothing my parents are very
against credit cards and truly believe
cash is King I agree but I also think I
should get a credit card to build credit
and get cash back points Etc I'm
wondering if you have any advice on what
to do with the inheritance that's
sitting there the money that I'm making
and if I should get a credit card I
would love to invest in real estate but
would love to hear from you first
well Sarah uh thanks for the question it
sounds like you got a lot going on a lot
of different questions let's tackle the
first Numero Uno question what to do
with the 75k hey if it's me you have no
debt I'm making sure that I've got three
to six months of expenses right George
that's thing one my guess is maybe she
does if she's been living at home but if
she doesn't if you don't have other
savings we need to take a portion of
that and allocate it to an emergency
fund correct and then if that's the case
or let's say you already had your
savings I'm looking at a down payment
George I'm trying to get up out of the
parents basement not to say that you're
living in the basement I'm just saying
I'm trying to get out of my parents
house at this point and see about life
on my own and maybe that's uh an
apartment at first because you know if
you have no debt and you have no credit
history like George George made a very
good point earlier about making sure
that you've established credit history
with um your parents as renters
so to speak and that you're actually
paying rent to your parents so when it's
time to get a mortgage they can actually
look at those payment histories as a way
to do some manual underwriting I'll let
George explain that but that's first
thing that I'm thinking is let me get
out of my parents house and uh so George
why don't you talk to that real estate
question a little bit as far as
investing oh the manual on the right
yeah okay the underwriting so part of
your question is do I get the credit
card to build a credit and get the cash
back you don't need to play that game at
all Jade and I have both gotten
mortgages with no credit history no
credit score because once we got out of
debt the credit score disappears into
the abyss that's right it becomes you
don't miss it zero and so you go well
indeterminable what does the lender do
then well they do what's called a no
score loan manual underwriting a lot of
lenders actually do this you just have
to do your research and our friends at
Churchill Mortgage have been doing this
forever and uh here's what you want to
do get in touch with them to figure out
what this looks like for you living at
home you you need to have some kind of
rental history that's a fact which means
you need to have been paid your parents
a sum of money consistently around the
same time every single month for one
year and it needs to be a sum that makes
sense for instance before Sam and I
bought our first house we did rent from
his mom she owned a property we rented
but we paid a reasonable rent she I
think she rented to us at Cost but every
month we wrote her a check for twelve
hundred dollars and so we were able to
use that as our uh rental history and so
that was able to work for us zero credit
score and there may be other history of
payments they want to look at like your
cell phone bill so you said you have no
bills I would just get more clarity on
that so that you're not shocked a year
from now but if you are going to be
buying a home I'd have a clear timeline
I wouldn't just continue living at home
with Mom and Dad for the foreseeable
future until you feel like it I would
say hey one year from now my goal is to
move out I want to start making payments
to you guys so I have rental history and
I have some skin in the game start
paying some bills around here and then
one year from now I'm going to continue
saving that inheritance can go sit in a
high heel savings account because you've
got a short-term goal so we don't want
to invest this money into the market
when we need this money that's right in
the next few years she's also talking
about in real investing in real estate
George
Le there's a lot of aspiring Real Estate
Investors out there in their 20s and I
love that and we love real estate around
here but there's a time and place for it
and it is once you've got a primary
residence paid off you're in baby step
seven no debt in the world then save up
and pay cash for Real Estate then and
only then and it reduces risk it
increases your cash flow which is what
it's all about right reduces your stress
from being a landlord at 23 while trying
to get out there as an adult there's
just there's a lot going on in your life
and you don't need to be a real estate
investor tomorrow yeah let's take it one
thing at a time you can build wealth
without that and so I would just focus
on increasing your income that might and
it sounds like you love the non-profit
space that's great if you want to stay
there if you want to move to the private
sector you might you know double your
income depending on what you're doing
and then the credit cards you just
simply don't need you've survived this
along without them and you're doing
great you're doing so much better than
most people who have credit cards and so
what does that tell you about wealth
building credit cards aren't a part of
the game
they're not a part of it there you go
well thanks for the the question Sarah
there's a lot packed in there thinking
about the right things and I I have a
lot of faith in Sarah that she's going
to build wealth quickly at this age
absolutely all right let's move on to
the phones we've got Lisa over in Dover
Delaware didn't mean to rhyme but I did
it anyways Lisa how you doing good
how what's going on so
we're 1662 and we have two cars and we
realize we don't need two cars and we
have two car payments so the one vehicle
has a lot of equity in it because of the
type of vehicle it is so we know we're
definitely selling that I I've got a
couple different options my husband
wants to sell that vehicle take the
proceeds and put it in our retirement
account
I want to get rid of both vehicles buy
the best car we can for let's just say
25 000 that way we have no car payments
and we can take that money and start
doubling up on our mortgage
um the only problem with that on the
second vehicle it's a hybrid so we got a
7 500 tax credit last year and if we
dispose of that car within three years
we have to recapture 66 two-thirds
percent of that 7 500. but my theory is
if you have no car payments that
recapture penalty will go away in four
four months so you'd lose out on about
five grand that you'd have to pay back
to the IRS right so my husband's like
I'm not paying the IRS well it sounds
like you guys are you're wanting to do a
lot of things at once you're wanting to
invest you're wanting to save it you
want to pay off the cars and so I would
focus on one thing at a time and the
best thing you can do right now is to
get out of all Consumer Debt so are
there two car loans you're only debt or
is there other things
a line of credit on on the house because
you've got a HELOC how much is it
I want to say 30.
okay so we got how much what are the car
loans add up to
the car line I just looked at that I
just about fell out of my chair while I
was on hold
um there's 70 000. wow what's your
household income 150. that's a lot of
cars
yeah okay well I love the idea of
selling the cars and both of them yeah
the 5K while it hurts you could call a
stupid tax because that loan is going to
hurt you even more uh hanging on to that
thing so let's see here if you sold one
car
what would that give you the one that
has uh more equity in it
143 extra a month all right and would
you clear any money is it worth more
than you owe oh yeah we'd probably clear
20. that's good okay and then what's
left on the other loan on the hybrid
51 000. oh wow sell these cars
every life crisis decision I made so it
was stupid it was definitely stupid I
regret it it's fun to drive but oh you
know it's more fun retiring yes when you
want to what's that it's more fun to
retire when you want to uh yeah my
husband had a health scare and that's
kind of accelerated our retirement too
what are we doing and let's let's ditch
this debt and be able to enjoy our life
yeah I mean the solutions right in front
of you selling these cars and and you
sell both of them you buy something
that's within range maybe you spend
twenty thousand dollars on something and
then you you know whatever you have in
this line of credit clear that out
that's a much better situation than what
you're in today right
right it's just his his theory is he
does not want to pay back the stupid tax
you know he's like let's just hold on to
it we'll take the money that we had on
the other car and we'll just but he
doesn't see the film he doesn't see the
the 70k of car payments as stupid taxes
tonight because I think he doesn't yeah
I like I said I didn't realize so I
started pulling the financial
um you know the loan paper worked out
and I'm like totally tell them to listen
to this episode that Jaden George told
him that that's the stupid tax if he was
so keen on investing he should have
spent all that money he spent on the
cars and put that into retirement if he
was such a retirement fiend so I'm
selling these cars get rid of the HELOC
next become completely debt free get a
fully funded emergency fund then we can
have a ball investing that is the plan
for progress and you guys can get there
with that great income but we got to
start focusing today that's right thanks
for the call Lisa this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel Ramsay personality joined
by my colleague and friend Jade warshaw
this hour yeah you know George it's a
new year thank you a lot and that means
you can't be given up on those goals
that you set out to accomplish and if
your main goal is to build those money
muscles but you've only been to the gym
I love this but you've only been to the
money gym once just like everyone else
it's time to make progress not excuses
that's what I'm talking about and let me
tell you it can be hard when you don't
have a plan or when you're starting out
with 460 thousand dollars of debt like
me
in my husband Sam man if you want to be
practical if you want to prove and plan
to climb out from under that pile of
bills and start Building Wealth it is
time right now to grab yourself a copy
of The Total Money Makeover guys do not
wait to do this this is your life change
right here this book is literally quite
literally the reason that I'm here today
on the radio this is Dave's best-selling
book for a reason guys you are going to
learn the seven baby steps to guide you
through your journey with real life
stories from people who don't have to
struggle with money problems anymore
because they followed the same steps too
guys I cannot tell you how much this can
change your life these baby steps I
remember when Sam and I first got The
Total Money Makeover we brought the book
home we started filling it out and I'll
be honest because it's like looking in
the mirror George we first looked at and
we're like oh my gosh and at first we've
kind of felt like oh man like a little
bit like can we do this and then we kept
reading we kept looking at the stories
and we were able to go forward so guys
let me be real with you real quick
paying off debt and Building Wealth it's
not just for me it's not just for those
people over there it's not just for the
Joneses it's for you or the people in
this book it's for you too to so get
back on that money treadmill and order
your copy of The Total Money Makeover
today this is at ramseysolutions.com
store you guys got this man you got this
order your copy today I love it can I
start telling people that I do go to the
gym I just go to the money gym the money
gym does that count it's like when you
like have two like
things of money in your fists and you
just like do curls just maxing out an
IRA yeah that's my kind of workout right
there oh I was really talking about like
lifting piles of cash oh no I can no
that would be baller though it feels
dangerous if I'm doing it at the gym I'm
getting mugged can I tell you something
I'm talking about piles of cash do you
remember when we were kids DuckTales and
he used to dive into that pile of money
and swim in it
if only that was possible let me tell
you that is that would be my money sadly
it's one of my retirement goals
just get one of those like inflatable
Walmart pools and we just fill it with
money I love it it's for sure gonna be
dollar bills I can't afford to do it
with tens I definitely want to see a
YouTube video of this George one I feel
like Mr Beast has done this someone will
let us know that's incredible
I love it I love it the guy's behind the
glass are like yeah please get Mr Beast
on a collab video with George swimming
in a pool of money oh but we'll talk
Total Money Makeover it's legit there's
not many books I would say are like
life-changing yeah if you do the steps
in them yeah this is the one that like
you can't you can't walk away not fired
up you can't walk away and not do
anything the stories the stories are
real everyday people and then I don't
know if they still have it but we have
the workbook version we had the book
version and the workbook where you can
like plug in all your numbers and see
what you're looking like and I can tell
you it's hard to look in the mirror but
you need to you need to see all the
areas that have just gotten since we're
using the fitness reference all those
Flappy money love handles oh
this feels like a personal attack it's
personal you got you got the the credit
card cellulite you know what I'm saying
yeah that's a new one for me I gotta
admit cellulite what a deep gun no one
likes that oh you got the can I should I
keep going I want to say something for
back fat but I can't get nervous it's
getting dark real quick some people have
already tuned out
I hope not come on George let's keep it
real all right let's get to the phones
it's your show America give us a call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Matthew is in Grand Rapids Matthew
welcome to the Ramsay show hey guys how
you doing doing great how can we help
yeah so first I want to give a quick
comment I submitted for the student loan
repayment since we paid them off during
covid and I checked my Nelnet didn't
Loan account today and I found out they
are making me pay that back and if I
didn't find that out by June 30th I
would have student loan interest I would
have to pay on top of that bill this
morning paid that right back so just
wanted to give a little awareness let me
get this clear Matthew you made your
payments and they said hey we'll
actually refund you ten thousand dollars
they reinstate your balance to 10 and
say hey hopefully the government clears
that
yep so I got a check from the Department
of Education in November last year for
that 10 grand and my balance was 10
grand so then next thing I uh they said
by June 30th so I didn't pay that back
I'd have interest to pay on top of that
and since there was some cares act thing
I actually have to obtain an additional
20 because from 20 20 of Interest
accrued which is gracious excuse to
confuse me so uh probably some not nice
words our Lord and savior wouldn't want
me to stay on there so they wrote my 10
grand and then put you in debt for
another 10 grand and said all right good
luck pay it off wow
okay a good reminder for those out there
that got a check check your balances
because they're probably reinstated for
that same amount go pay that off
immediately good looking out Matthew and
it's interesting you know I was on a
couple weeks back with Dave and a guy
called in and something really similar
he had the he had requested a refund for
the 10K and when they gave him the
refund they reinstated his entire loan
and they sent him a check for the amount
of the entire loan not just for the way
more than 10K way more I think it was
like 20 it was a weird number it was
like 21 or 22 something and this is what
I was afraid of which is you know gross
predatory malpractice from these student
loan companies it's predatory and but
but Matt did the right thing he sent
that check right back and that's what
y'all need to do if you're listening and
you requested student loan forgiveness
especially if you were already clear of
debt just be debt free man amen just be
debt free send that money back and be
debt free quit waiting on the government
love it well Matthew let's get to your
question is it related unrelated yeah uh
not directly related to this just had a
quick question so my wife and I
debt-free other than our house we uh
make about 120 000 a year combined my
company uh matches about eight to nine
percent in our 401K I have about like 50
000 in there so far and my question is
should I only match up to the eight to
nine percent and then go with a smart
investor Pro for the other uh six six to
seven percent or should I max out that
401k to the 15 and then let them uh
match up to that eight or nine do you
have a Roth 401k
I believe so it's uh after it's uh after
tax
it is after tax so therefore to make
sure it's a Roth if it's a Roth you can
just invest all 15 into that 401k
okay and you should get close to maxing
it out I don't think you'll get there
with your income
okay but if it's if it's not a Roth if
it's a traditional then we would just
into the Roth IRA yeah and Max that out
or get us as high as you can up to the
15.
okay that sounds good kids because yeah
I have that 15 just taken out of my
paycheck every single week cool yeah
it's great if it's a Roth if it's not we
want you to take advantage of in this
order match beats Roth beats traditional
so take that match up to nine percent
let's go to the Roth IRA and start
putting some money in there then if we
run out of options we can go back to the
traditional 401k to finish it out
okay is that a baby in the background I
hear yeah she we're we're just pulling
up uh uh she was just crying a little
bit in the car seat so I was trying to
keep her as calm as possible and that
that's what I was just gonna say so
should that shouldn't change anything
since she's about nine months old just
keep investing uh like we are yeah I
mean I'd open a 529 and beyond that 15
throw a little chunk of money into a 529
every month or an ESA
okay my parents and I partnered on that
so we're good to go there I love it man
what an awesome dad Matthew pump for you
I know how old are you
uh 25. oh my goodness you guys are in
such great shape thank you so much for
the call what what an awesome scenario I
love your problem to have it never gets
old George when people are doing the
right thing I wish I was that smart at
25. like you know if you're listening
you're frustrated because you're like
gosh I wish I you know you have all you
always hear this yeah man I wish I knew
this when I was younger hindsight is 20
20. you know what it's not too late we
got a call from the 56 year old saying I
want to get out of debt we got a call
from a 62 year old saying I want to
retire with dignity it's never too late
so if you're listening and you're 40 or
50 or 60 and you hear these youngsters
who are debt free and they're all
they're going to be millionaires it's
not too late for you you can create a
better tomorrow you might have to work
longer you might have to sacrifice you
might have to downsize but you can
retire with dignity you don't have to
die with loans in your life leaving your
family in a Lurch and leaving you with
no Legacy that's not what I want for
anyone listening and you can change that
so good hour Jay thank you so much let's
do more of it coming up on the Ramsey
Show we'll be back
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolution.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm your host George Campbell
Join This Hour by Jake warshaw and we're
taking your calls at
888-825-5225 you jump in we'll have a
conversation about your life and your
money Bill kicks us off in Macon Georgia
Phil welcome to the Ramsay show my
friend
all right thanks for taking my call
absolutely what's going on
well me and my wife are working on baby
step one uh we
purchased a home in May of last year and
between then and now we switched
insurance companies for the home
insurance so our payment would go down
we could bundle some of us that would
just help to help us out a little bit
um that insurance company that we went
to sent some inspectors out to just kind
of look at the property and they said
our roof was old now we knew our roof
was on its way out when we bought the
house the the insurance people are
telling us that we have until September
of this year to switch the roof over for
the insurance will last
now I want to get through baby step one
first but my question is once we get
that thousand dollar emergency fund
should we pause uh on baby step two and
just sock money away for the roof or
what would your recommendation be there
absolutely I mean this is what we would
call kind of a storm mode
um number one you got to cover the four
walls before we do anything else food
utilities shelter transportation and you
literally need this roof over your head
and your home insurance lapsing could
put you in a really really dangerous
scenario and so are you going to be able
to cash flow the new roof or the roof
repair what does this look like
uh right now no uh We've caught or
we've cut all the expenses we know to
cut I'm working 60 to 70 hours a week at
my job now my wife will be taking up a
job hopefully a hospital here before too
long she's a registered nurse she's just
waiting on a license to reinstate back
to Georgia great so
after that we should be looking pretty
good she said she's a low ball would be
like 800 extra dollars a month so that
would really help
so what's the roof going to cost
average cost it looks like it's going to
be about five to six thousand dollars
okay uh we may be able to speak by a
little under that but I'm not sure
exactly
and what are your minimum payments on
your debt
oh are you able to afford all the
minimum payments and keep all your bills
current
yeah we're we're good right now hers
would just give us a little bit more uh
one more margin to kind of knock down
all that other debt because you should
be able to do this with her extra 800
bucks and you've got I'm guessing a few
extra 100 bucks you could throw at this
roof right now
want to do that kind of actually yeah
okay so that would put it at about six
months of saving to pay for this roof
which means by the summer time this
thing's done and we're continuing
continuing on with the baby steps
attacking that smallest debt uh next in
baby step two
cool that'll be my plan my plan would be
let's try to beat that goal and say hey
can we get this money saved up by April
by May
so we don't delay our debt Freedom any
longer
all right so I'd be continuing to work
those 60 70 hours let's hope she gets
that job and works as much as she can
let's get a bunch of estimates to see
who who's got the best bid on this job
and then move forward from there
awesome all right thanks so much Phil
appreciate the call Jesse is up next in
Memphis Tennessee Jesse welcome to the
show
hey thanks for having me guys no problem
what's going on
uh so general question uh we are in baby
step one
and I started uh side hustling
and I was curious on how much I should
withhold from that since it's
uh cash to pay for taxes at the
beginning of next year that's great
that's a really good question Jesse I'm
happy that you're thinking about this
because so many people you know they
start on a job where they're responsible
for the taxes at 1099 and then tax
season rolls around and they get hit
with a bill so I'm really happy that
you're thinking about this especially
early uh in the year so what I would do
um anytime I used to be an entertainment
and then a lot of times we would get
paid just a flat rate and we were
responsible for the taxes and so as good
measure what we would do is just set
aside you know 25 to 30 percent of the
earnings and put that with our quarterly
estimate and um that's how we made sure
that we didn't get hit with a big tax
bill at the at the end of the year
awesome yeah my wife was the one who
because I didn't think about it at all I
was just I'm focused on making extra and
she said hey you know make sure you hold
out for taxes I'm like it's a great idea
yeah how much so you don't want the IRS
on your back man how much are you
bringing in 10.99
uh well I just started uh last week and
it's probably gonna look like
maybe five or six hundred a month okay
yeah yeah just put a quarter of that
aside and then you'll be ready ready
when that tax bill comes and what I did
when I was doing side hustles it is made
quarterly estimated payments and I did
that through the IRS website make sure
it's official but that really set me up
for Success because at the end of the
year I didn't have this giant bill to
pay instead I was keeping up with it
throughout the year and you can actually
get dinged with penalties and fees if
you don't make those quarterly estimated
payments that's really that's that's
exactly right George George makes a
really good point so I would go on the
IRS website you can just search
quarterly estimated payments and begin
making payments again it's estimated so
if you take hey I'm gonna put 25 30 and
pay it to the IRS every quarter to keep
them off my back they'll be happy
it's awesome that sounds like a great
idea what are you doing for side hustles
uh doordash okay how much are you making
in doordash because a lot of listeners
out there are wondering what's worth
their time what's what's going to make
them the most money
well last week was my first week and
I averaged 26 55 an hour nice I did it I
did it for uh I did three evenings
uh so it's almost nine hours is all I
put in and it was 26.55 an hour that's
great and you're doing this to pay off
some debt
correct yeah right we're learning baby
step one uh we just started this month
so we'll have that baby step done by the
end of the month so next month we can
start
pushing my snowball off the cliff how
much debt
say that again how much debt
oh lord it's uh
say 26 000 credit cards and
Maybe
maybe 80 000 in cars that's a lot of
cars it is I'm wondering if you're
households and cars
yeah uh my wife was considering selling
her car but when we financed it she was
we was upside down on the other one and
she went to uh Kelley Blue Book Blue
Book to see how much it was worth what's
your household income it yeah
the household before the doordash was
uh right at 100 per year man you guys
need to get out of these cars yeah the
good news is you're willing to do
whatever it takes the bad news is
whatever it takes happens to be selling
one or both of these cars yeah this is
just too much car for you man that's
over way over 50 percent of your
household income tied up in a
depreciating asset and it's it's
drowning you guys and I want to see the
side hustle be put to work and uh
getting rid of these cars will
definitely get you there appreciate the
call man way to go hustling this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsay
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour
well guys if you're wondering whether to
buy or sell a home this year here's what
you need to know about the housing
market there's still more demand for
homes than there are homes to buy the
median home price is expected to keep
Rising just at a slower rate and
interest rates likely haven't stopped
going up so what does that mean for you
well if you're buying a home you may
still face some competition and big
price tags and if you want to sell your
home chances are that you can still make
a nice profit but you may have to be
patient for the right offer to come it's
not going to happen overnight of course
this will depend on where you are every
Market is so different and it's why you
need to work with an experienced real
estate agent when you're ready to start
the home buying or home selling process
you want someone who's done this a
hundred of times before and knows how to
negotiate a strong deal based on this
current market and you can find agents
like that who are Ramsay trusted through
our endorsed local providers program
these are top performing agents around
the country who we trust to serve you
well get connected today at
ramseysolutions.com
agent that's ramseysolutions.com agent
James is up next right here in Nashville
Tennessee James welcome to the show
hello hey what's going on how you doing
I'm doing great uh uh first of all I'd
like to thank you all for taking my call
and thank you for your show it's been
very helpful absolutely glad to hear it
what's going on with you well
and um
I'm sitting on about 240 000 and uh it's
just sitting in a bank doing nothing for
me and also I have some annuities as
well that are matured which uh
which I'm looking to uh maybe I can
start collecting on that but it's like a
long-term payout you know so I thought I
might start getting that having all the
deposit into a bank account and maybe
dollar cost to average that into some
sort of investment that's uh maybe a
diversification of things in a little
higher Mission some more safe
um how old are you
I am 62. all right do you have any other
retirement you have a nest egg
well I my income is tax free it's
annuity as well and uh from an action I
had been in years ago and uh it's pretty
good uh I mean my income is pretty good
I get about 5500 a month 5500 a month
and that's tax-free and it's all tax
free and is that guaranteed for the rest
of your life or what yes it is yeah okay
and that's essentially your retirement
yeah yeah it is yeah all right well and
you're not you said you sold the house
where are you living now
oh I'm actually I'm I've got another
place I just just right across the river
here on the Cumberland River and uh I'm
just I'm doing the same thing here just
a little RV property I'm looking a
little more uh you know more traveling
type uh of uh lifestyle for a while
while I can you know cool tell them too
all to do it I have another property up
north which I was gonna develop it and
put a barn on it make it RV friendly
like a seasonal type uh of property and
that is the property paid off
everything's paid off I'm dead oh
wonderful okay and what what other money
do you have in in savings you said you
have 240. any other cash well and that's
about it and I have about 60 in the
annuities I was telling you about
they're pretty much matured two of them
are I just didn't let it ride for the
last couple years because uh I wasn't
exactly sure what I want to do with it
and it's a long-term payout too on some
of that probably most of it um so I was
thinking about taking that and like I
said dollar cost and they have that
deposit into an accountant and I find
the right investment have that dollar
cost into you know I'm thinking there's
going to be some Bargains going on with
the way the economy is it's getting
ready to tank or if it hasn't you know
you know well I like dollar cost
averaging and if you want to do that
into mutual funds index funds you know
don't do this into single stocks or
anything volatile but that would be a
good plan and the rest of the 240 if you
want to I would if you're gonna need it
liquid cash in the next few years for
anything you're doing I would put it in
a high yield savings account for now but
if you're talking you know four five six
plus years out you can invest that and I
like the idea of dollar cost averaging
it you could also lump sum it
yeah yeah I'd like to dial across down
you know this way I can get them uh line
the market on its way down and a little
bit on its way back up maybe a little
set up and then you go ahead and cash it
all in in a few years and then just you
know live off the rest absolutely I mean
I'll check my lifestyle up a little bit
as uh well I'd be looking at my future
goals James and going all right do I
want to put this towards the farm that I
want to rebuild you know you want to
have liquid cash for that I don't want
it fluctuating in the market and you
take a big hit on it because you wanted
to invest it and all of a sudden the
market dipped a little and now it hurts
emotionally to take that money out at a
loss so leave as much as you need in
cash in a high yield savings account
that'll grow at about three or four
percent right now in a good online high
yield savings account the rest I would
uh put towards those goals whether
that's investing or using way to go man
good problems to have all right Rebecca
is up next in Iowa City Rebecca welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi thanks so much for having me today
absolutely how can we help
yeah so um I've been working full-time
while I'm in a full-time online graduate
program and I just completed my third
class of a 10 class program and I'm set
to graduate in May of 2024 and my
employer is covering the cost of the
program and it's not a requirement of my
position but I also just found out I'm
pregnant which I'm really excited about
congrats
um but my classes for the next semester
start tomorrow and so my question is if
you think I should continue with the
program but I'm not really necessarily
sold on and requires quite a bit of time
but is paid for by my employer or if I
should kind of take some time and focus
on kind of family and reevaluating my
career options
so the grad school is not costing you
anything out of your pocket right
yeah that's correct so when you talk
about taking a pause is that like what
do you plan on doing with that time
yeah I guess um just kind of getting
ready this is our first kid so just kind
of getting ready for that situation I
suppose and we just bought a house this
year so kind of working on that I guess
so if you took a pause from grad school
and you picked up work it would allow
you to pile up cash since you have a
baby coming which a lot of times we
would recommend people if they're
working the baby steps you know to pause
the baby steps pile up cash and get
ready for that you know that big
adventure of having a new baby in the
world
um is that kind of what you're thinking
when you say take a pause is this a
chance for you to work or this is just
kind of like me time
yeah I have been um working full-time so
I would continue doing that okay just
kind of be more having my evenings and
like mornings and weekends available
again since it does take so much of my
outside of work time could you restart
this grad program later on if you wanted
to
um yes I think I could then I don't see
why not if you can pick up when you're
ready and you know go at it again and
there's no penalty or you're not losing
out on any money from it being paid for
I would say take a break especially if
you're not really like you said you're
not sold on it it'll give you some time
to kind of reevaluate if that's really
what you want to do going forward and
again it's no it's no cost to you so
what's your household income currently
um it's 102 about right now awesome how
much of that is yours
um I make like 47 ish
cool and where are you guys at
financially in the baby steps are you
out of debt with an emergency fund
yeah we are we're out of debt with an
emergency fund working on paying off our
house but I guess we need to pay for
college now amazing that's exciting yeah
and maybe start that like separate
little sinking fun for baby yes and make
sure that you you and baby come home
healthy and there's going to be some you
know medical costs with that and of
course goodness gracious all the baby
gear and diapers and formula and all
that stuff so it's going to be a new
budget line item uh so don't freak out
about that but it doesn't hurt to save
up an extra 10 grand outside of the
emergency fund for these types of costs
wonderful that would be my next goal for
you as well yeah I love it I always like
to save up the deductible because you
know you're going to hit the deductible
when you have that max out of pocket
deductible so look into that on your
health insurance plan and uh we're
rooting for you Rebecca that's awesome
that's exciting yeah it's nice to have
options too and you can just pause
because you're not desperate you're not
paying for it yes and that's the thing
if you were doing this grad program with
student loans well now the pressure's on
yeah that's what I love about the baby
steps is ultimately that's what you're
giving your ourselves you're giving
yourself option to choose you don't have
this debt hanging around your neck I
always think you know whenever you have
that kind of debt all of your choices
are filtered through that it's like can
I afford to do this well if I do this I
won't pay off this debt in time and when
you get debt free it allows you the
freedom to choose oh yeah Ford Motor
Company doesn't call the shots Sallie
Mae's not calling the shots you do yeah
even career-wise you do work that you
love you do work that matters that's a
nice work to pay the bills absolutely
more of your calls coming up triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to Christian Healthcare
Ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
Health Care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the Better Business Bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five well
Jade the headlines have not been what I
expected lately All the Rage eggs eggs
it's all anyone can talk about here's
the CNN Headline egg prices exploded 60
percent higher last year these food
prices surge too it goes on to say
grocery prices remain stubbornly high
nearly double the rate of overall
inflation at 11.8 percent year over year
according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics none have been more rotten
than egg prices up 59.9 percent year
over year a rate not seen since 1973. oh
my goodness wow well you know they get
the phrase a dime a dozen from eggs
right I did not know that they used to
be a dime a dozen and that's where they
got that from and now apparently they're
59.9 percent higher and they have eggs
floated I see what you did there this
feels like the old like I I walked
uphill both ways and eggs were a dime a
dozen yeah yeah it is but I will say
when I get to the grocery store and I
look at my Pete and Jerry's you know
organic dozen and it's like almost eight
dollars
this economy are you kidding me look
George there's some there's some things
I just can't compromise on now back in
the day we can't afford GMO let alone
organic if I was in baby step two I
would take whatever egg they had but
your girl moved out of baby stuff too
just eggs butter and margarine up 35
lettuce is up almost 25 annually flour
prepared flour mixes up to 23 annually
canned fruits and veggies up 18 annually
bread up 16 annually but here's the good
news the Silver Lining and all of this
what bacon is down almost four percent
annually interesting so it's a wash if
you got your eggs you get your Bacon's
cheaper you get to cheer you get to
choose one or the other wow well we
wanted to give people some tips here Jay
because it we like to make some jokes
because it's all wild out there but it
is hard to when you go to the grocery
store and you've gotta swipe that debit
card or get that cash envelope out it
hurts it does hurt and it hurts so bad
that I started looking for Alternatives
I started looking for suggestions and I
saw this video online that some some
psycho had the nerve to post it's
instead of doing scrambled eggs for
breakfast it's scrambled tofu
some some crazy person you posted that
video did post that video George and
you're trying to cause Anarchy you know
what here's the deal I love eggs I will
eat eggs but when eggs are costing me
8.99 I would rather get a pack of tofu
for a dollar 79 it feeds my whole family
and they have the seasoning I don't even
know what's sprinkle in it and it tastes
like it how are they making it 1.79 I
don't trust it and it's organic George
it was never real to begin with tofu
soybeans bro uh oh I'm learning a lot
it's soybean it's just hardened soybeans
I'm telling you look I've I have looked
for all the Alternatives you know you
can make an egg out of flax seed like if
you're making pancakes or waffle you can
make a flax egg
that doesn't sound right it's flax seeds
the Lord intended it George look flax
seed eggs I'm always looking for
Alternatives out here you you are like
next level when it comes to food so I
believe you and if Jade was cooking it
George I'm sure if you come to my house
and I have leftover waffles if you have
those waffles you are go I always say
you're gonna rip off your shirt and run
through the streets wow ranting about
how delicious these waffles that's not
what America needs right now gosh but
there are other things you can do right
at the end of the day it's all about
making a budget being very specific in
your food budget right yes and here's
what's happening Jade people see these
headlines and it makes them spiral even
further about the economy and they it
gets political yeah and there's a lot of
reasons for these food prices
skyrocketing supply chain issues still a
problem Transportation costs it just
costs more to move things across the
country yeah uh there's Global factors I
mean there's a war happening I don't
know if you've heard about it with
Russia and Ukraine uh bird flu that
happened which is causing a lot lot of
these these egg prices the thing is
gorgeous I don't want to focus I can't
change that I can't change the War I
can't change the bird flu I can't change
supply chain but what I can do is I can
meal plan you can change that budget I
can change my budget if I can't afford
eggs I need to cook stuff that has less
eggs in it right I can absolutely
control the controllables right and I
love this meal planner on
ramseysolutions.com uh that you can take
a look through it's yeah our friend
Rachel Cruz produced this and it's been
updated but at the time you know we
didn't experience all this inflation now
we need this and so you can get this
incredible guide at ramseysolutions.com
meal planner and it also includes a
grocery savings guide there's some
templates you can print out for meal
planning grocery shopping there's a ton
of tips in there and it's completely
free for you you can also check out our
article on why food prices are going up
we've got all of that for you in the
show notes as well if you're watching
the show listening to the show but there
are some things we can do and we've
mentioned some of them on the show
before but doing your research not just
buying willy-nilly impulsively but
actually researching where the best
spots are to go what's on sale that week
using what you already have that's right
you don't want to reach back in that
pantry and go oh that that went bad you
know George January is a great month to
do a pantry challenge yes and just cook
all that stuff in there you got black
beans in there you got some old blue box
macaroni and cheese in there you have
some old noodles that are creative yeah
get creative you better fix those
noodles fix them they don't go bad who
cares on top of that of course buying
generic brands we know you love your
name brand this or that it's the same
thing generic it's made in the same
Factory they just slap a different label
on it and one of the hardest things
switching where you Shop grocery wise
that one is emotional for some people
yeah you know you know where everything
is and every aisle and it's very
comforting yeah if you can save 20 30 40
50 bucks by going to Aldi worth it do it
and then freezing your meals a lot of
times food goes bad because is you just
let it sit and so freeze that junk
George if you look in my freezer you're
gonna see a single hot dog bun Frozen
you're gonna see she's freezing
everything you're gonna see a clove of
garlic that's been frozen you're gonna
see an individual veggie I freeze
everything wow my friends make fun of me
but trust trust and believe the time
will come when you want to make a hot
dog and you need that hot dog bun we're
thawing it out in 2023. God help that's
the advice that's the slogan and of
course if you're not budgeting you gotta
start because it's one of the main
reasons you're feeling the pinch you're
not paying attention to where your
money's going yes you need to make some
sacrifices but you have to know where to
make those sacrifices and understand
what you're currently spending yeah and
we've got a great app for you called
every dollar to help you do that I love
every dollar I love every dollar because
I never just put like a food line item
it's like a grocery store household
items restaurants if there's a holiday
you know Thanksgiving you know whatever
the holiday is I love being detailed in
that because that's when you really see
how you're spending right absolutely
lunch if you buy lunch at you know at
work yeah oh yeah now might be the time
to stop that's all I'm saying we've got
a cafeteria here at Ramsey Solutions and
that can be dangerous I'm much less
likely to meal prep every day oh yeah
you know I've been rolling through there
getting smoothies so I need to chill out
an incredible benefit but something else
I've done Jade because a lot of people
you know I posted that very
controversial Instagram reel and Tick
Tock saying hey it's cheaper to eat at
home yes than to eat out people freaked
out they got pitchforks George you are
in danger well what about all the my
time is that not worth anything I gotta
cook I gotta clean I'm using all these
pots and pans they're arguing with me
about the time it takes well these
people need to choose because you can't
hear George
you can't have it both ways all right
you can't go out here on this side and
complain about food prices and gas
prices and this and this and get all mad
about everything and then when we tell
you hey here's a way to make your life
better just simply XYZ you know start
budgeting start cutting back start look
you know and then you're saying no I
don't want to do that either I and it
gets into that that mindset of I deserve
I don't have to do anything I don't have
to do anything to change my situation I
don't have to do anything to make my
personal life in my home at my house
better I just get to Rave and complain
about politics about supply chain about
tipping about everything else I don't
have to do anything to change well
what's funny to me is they're throwing
Instagram reels to troll me in the
comments they could have uh used that
time to cook you could cook your meal if
your time is worth that much what are
you doing on social media bub you could
have cooked a whole hot dog there you go
and ate it at home and it would have
cost you if it was a Costco hot dog a
dollar fifty but I'm just saying they're
holding down the line Costco was
speeding inflation single-handedly if
you want to change this you make changes
here's the question simple hot dogs are
up 16 what's in that hot dog Costco I
got a lot of questions how are you doing
this it's meat pieces George it's not
real meat well you love breakfast so we
can't trust you now Jade goodness
gracious well hope those tips help go to
ramseysolutions.com meal planner you can
check that out hope it helps you all
fight this wild wild inflation this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm Ramsey
personality George Campbell joined by
Jade warshaw this hour if you're
enjoying this show I would ask of you
one thing it doesn't require your money
it just takes you a second and here's
what it is consider subscribing to the
show leaving us a review wherever you're
listening and sharing this with a friend
word of mouth is how we make impact with
the show with the hope that we want to
spread when it comes to your money and
your life and we appreciate you doing
that out there in the real world on the
internet and with your friends yes love
it open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Francisco joins
us up next in Fort Lauderdale Francisco
welcome to the show
hey thank you so much Drive thanks for
taking my call we appreciate it yeah
Fort Lauderdale that's my old neck of
the woods Francisco
yeah
um
quickly
um I'm calling because I just I mean I'm
doing okay financially
um but I just feel like I could do much
better
and and I just just wanted to get your
perspective to see how I can maximize my
my wealth and um and to be on track with
the baby steps because I feel like at
the end of the month you know I just you
know there's always like very little
money left really to to put into to
savings and all that even though you
feel like you're following yeah like the
baby steps and the budget it just feels
like man so here's my situation so I I
have
um you know I have my six-month
emergency fund I my take-home pay is
about 7 000 a month
um I have a rental income of 2400 so
that's
basically like 9 400 a month if I count
the rental income nice I have no debt
except my mortgage and I'm also leasing
or what they will call fleecing a car
okay
um and I've been doing it
um I've always released how much is the
lease because the lease is
358 okay
okay and I have like three years left
and so I want to kind of get in kind of
get On Track of the baby step so if I
were to because I know you guys
encourage a lot to buy used and buy good
reliable cars and you you know but my
only concern with that is
um eventually when you buy used even if
it's a good car I mean eventually that
car will break down right any car can
break down
any car can break down at any point
right but with the lease you have that
kind of like Insurance uh or at least
for that time period that you lease it
you always have that that warranty and
and that peace of mind that you're
driving with them okay here's the thing
Francisco let's talk about let's talk
about this budget here okay and then
we'll talk about the car situation so it
sounds like you have 9 500
a month did I get that straight as your
income correct okay and my screen says
that you want to get back on track with
the baby steps so you've already you've
already walked through the baby steps up
until baby step 3B basically so you've
got your three to six months of expenses
saved are you currently doing any
investing
for baby step four yeah yes so that's
the thing I kind of feel like I'm doing
the baby steps all of them at the same
time why is that I'm putting 50 I've
been putting 15 on on retirement I've
been doing it for a while
um I have like
uh combined retirement with me and my
wife we have like maybe
530k right in in my traditional tsp okay
with a Roth IRA
so where are you running into tell me
kind of what your what's your question
like where where are you running into
issues because it sounds like you're
doing a lot of things right
yeah my thing is what I feel like I'm
not doing what you know right is is the
whole issue with you know with leads
with that leasing car that's the only
area where I feel like maybe that's like
really my my debt and also I don't feel
like I'm contributing enough to my kids
um 529 okay
um I feel like I could do much I mean
let's let's talk about that okay so
you've got the 9500 you have no debt
you're investing 15 so we're doing baby
steps four five six
um at the same time simultaneously so
you're I mean you may have skipped you
may have skipped around in the past but
for all intents and purposes right get
rid of that lease and get you a used car
in cash you're right on track yeah so
you're not as far as you think and then
you've got the income that you should be
able to do four five and six at the same
time you should have enough money I mean
your lease is not super excited I don't
I'm not vouching for the lease but it's
not like it's you know this a thousand
dollar thing that's cutting into all
your money you should have have the
money to do what you need to do it
sounds like this is a budget thing it
sounds like you guys are spending a lot
yes and and well
we I don't that's the thing you know I I
feel like we can do much better on the
budget and I also had another question
with the course of the budget with a
zero-sum budget because I get paid
bi-weekly and usually the biggest
payments are due in the first days of
the month yeah and so if I were to put a
number on every month so that at the end
of the month is zero I mean how do you
guys I mean how does that work in for me
to cover those first payments from the
next on the following month if I had if
my budget is you know that's my thing so
mortgages do like in the first day of
the month so basically that extra
payment that I'm budgeting for or that
I'm putting a number for I mean I have
to kind of roll it over that's right so
that's what you need to do that's kind
of what you need to do so the things
that are due on the first right if you
don't have enough money on the first to
pay all of those things then you need to
kind of backtrack and make sure that as
you're planning the previous month so
for instance this is January so if
you're creating January's budget you you
need to make sure that you're accounting
for the fact in January that you have
rent due or mortgage due on February 1st
so it's to say that some of that money
might come in from the previous month
and there's a really great tool on every
dollar it's called paycheck planning and
you can literally go on there and plan
out how each dollar is spent and it even
gives you the option to roll money a
balance over from the previous month so
in your circumstance let's say it's
going to take you bringing five hundred
dollars from the previous month's budget
into that current month in order to make
that you know that February first
payment it actually allows you to do
that so if you don't have every dollar
let's get them set up with every dollar
and I think that that's really going to
be able to think that gets you in there
Francisco look you have a great income
you're making a lot of money if you want
to get out of this lease you could
probably buy your way out today or find
out what it's going to take to buy your
way out of that lease but at this point
it's really just you taking the money
that you have and using it properly with
that income you should be able to invest
fifteen percent put a little aside for
the 529s and also if you've got sounds
like the only debt you had was your
mortgage as a and also maybe some debt
on this rental but you should be able to
start climbing your way out of that
mortgage here soon what do you think
George yeah what's left on the mortgage
Francisco
so the mortgage I had I owe a total of
for the mortgage the it's like three
hundred and sixteen thousand dollars to
do this 30-year 316
000 to be paid off and I paid uh monthly
it's about 2400 including property taxes
and homeowners insurance okay so that's
that's not setting you back too much I
mean it's not it's not too expensive for
you is what I'm saying yeah I mean
you're running right with the extra
rental income it makes it reasonable now
your wife is working as well is that
included in the seven or is that uh no
that's only me my wife is a realtor so
you know it's not really like a fixed
income when one year she might you know
she might do well other there are other
years you know other times there might
be no sales for her so it's kind of like
very it's very hard to budget her income
um like last year she did pretty well
um well we need to get her budgeting as
well and you guys need to be doing it
together and so what this is is a
regular income we've got a great
um we have articles and resources on
this on ramseysolutions.com but what you
do is take the the lowest kind of
average month if you looked across 12
months what's the average what's kind of
the worst month she's actually done not
a zero dollar month and then we can go
all right if we take that and add it to
the budget we can start from there and
then if there's more on that we can
start moving it down beyond the four
walls Beyond to subscriptions and
luxuries and can we add more to the 529
if she gets even more so that really
helps with that side of things and with
every dollar premium which is what Jade
was talking about that includes that
paycheck planning feature which is going
to help you figure out hey where do
these bills fall are we going to run out
of money
which I think will give you confidence
right now you're going we make good
money I just don't understand where it's
all going and that's where the budget
comes into play but I'm going to figure
out the early buyout on that lease and
go ahead and just knock that out you've
got the money in the bank yeah let's get
a reasonable used car with cash it's
gonna be okay you can afford the
insurance and man you're never going to
look back with regret on that you guys
are doing great Francisco you just got
to tighten it up that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books my thanks
to Jade warshaw my co-host all the folks
in the booth and you America thanks for
tuning in we'll be back real soon
foreign
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour it's a free call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
call in and we'll give you the best
advice we can if you're at a Crossroads
you need a second opinion a third
opinion we are here for you unbiased but
also biased to the fact that we want you
to win financially and do it debt free
that's right I take that back Jade but
we can have our opinions that's true
it's the Ramsay show we got the Ramsay
opinion and uh you get what you paid for
Sean is up first in Kansas City Sean
welcome to the show
thank you for taking my call George and
Jade you're welcome to do it what's
going on
so I will be selling my home uh this
spring and my wife and I will be
purchasing a new home and my question is
whether I should roll all the profits
from my sale into the new home I'm
currently in baby step two we have
worked our deficit down to about 30 000
remaining which I had planned to have it
paid off in the fall
but if I put 10 to 15 down on the new
home then what we would have left over
from the profits would actually uh take
us out of baby step two and we would
have the fully funded emergency fund um
and baby step three and uh we've been
going through this for some time so I
kind of like the idea of jumping
kind of knocking out the debt having the
emergency fund with the new home
purchase but at the same time uh I'm not
sure if I should roll everything into
the new home and then keep working baby
step two if you were to put 20 percent
take 20 of the profit and put it towards
the new house would it give you enough
to do baby step two and how much of the
would you get three months out of it
three months of savings
uh no I don't believe so um depending on
what the sale is we would uh clear
between probably 75 and 85 and I think
we had 35 000 through Churchill Mortgage
um we were planning on plan 35 to 40 000
down okay and
what's the home sale price of the one
you're buying it'd be uh 175 to 200 is
what we would be selling and what we're
pre-approved for is 300.
okay so you're gonna put 40 down on a
house that you bought for how much
260 is the home
all right what's your take-home pay
uh together we bring
well I know we make ten thousand we
bring home ten thousand okay so ten
thousand take-home pay so we want that
mortgage to be about 25 of your
take-home pay and so if you put 40 down
on 260 that would put you right there
that is a that's a sweet spot
now if you put down 35 you'd still be
good so could you put down 35 and still
be able to pay off your debt
yes and have a emergency fund
yes oh
this is your rock and rolling man yeah
the odds are in your favor absolutely so
whatever the equity is we're paying off
the debt building an emergency fund the
rest is going to go towards that down
payment
perfect perfect I love it okay wow and
then what that does like you said a
catapult to you to Baby Steps four five
six so then we begin investing 15 of
that household income and then we still
have margin left over because we have a
very reasonable mortgage comparatively
to our take-home pay to pay off the
house early
oh yeah so you're doing this with a lot
of wisdom and and I hope it's a smooth
transition and move I I know it's a man
it's stressful even when you're in your
spot it's still just a lot mentally and
physically
yeah I know uh my wife she really wants
to get a baby step too
well you're doing it the right way Sean
we're proud of you man way to go and uh
good folks over there at Churchill all
right let's move on to Jackson in Dayton
Jackson welcome to the show
hey thanks George thanks Jade how you
guys doing today doing good how are you
I'm doing very well
what's going on all right hey so get
straight to the point my question is how
much money should I put into a used car
well that depends how much cash do you
have
well I guess like savings like am I
emergency funding like my savings well
yeah do you have any money that you've
started saving specifically for a car
like tell us a little bit more about the
situation
okay so about a month ago I hit a deer
oh yikes and uh yeah no fun
and my insurance totaled my car and
they're giving me about twenty eight
hundred dollars for it they're giving
you they're writing you a check for 2800
bucks
yes all right what other money do you
have in the bank
so
um and my actual savings I have about
say ten thousand dollars okay in my
emergency fund I have about eight
thousand
okay so let's say you've got about 20
000 to your name
yeah let's say that is that right
do you have any debt correct
I am actually debt free as and debt free
for uh my whole life nice personally way
to go way to go so the the goal here is
to not touch the emergency fund
and so let's say you said your emergency
fund was about 8 000 right now
correct okay so that gives us the 10 you
have saved plus the 2800 that the
insurance company is giving you
and so my goal would be can we get you a
twelve thousand dollar car
a twelve thousand dollar car okay it's
out is that laughable to you I hope not
because that's my budget for my next
used car
no no so I guess for me
for me it's like um how do I kind of
also preserve some of my savings I'm 20
years old and I guess my long-term goal
is like get a house someday and I do you
want to spend less than that on a car oh
so you want to go lower wow
perhaps maybe that's kind of go that's
great yeah I'm for I'm here for that I
mean you can find now they're going to
get a lot of haters but they're
literally out there for sale oh yeah six
thousand seven thousand eight thousand
that are that are great they're gonna be
higher mileage they're not going to be
the shiniest newest fanciest but it
sounds like you don't care about that I
just love that he's thinking this way no
I don't care about that right so you'd
rather allocate more money towards the
down payment what's your income
oh yeah so right now I'm only making
what uh say 28 000 a year okay for the
cobbler how old are you
I'm 20 years old oh yeah and are you in
school or do you go straight to the
trades and you're just going to continue
cobbling
I just went straight to work uh since
high school took your foundations of
personal finance senior year I was like
you know what I'm gonna try this out see
how it works that's great and your
income is going to go up I mean you're
20 years old you've got plenty of time
whether you continue cobbling and you
know build that out further or I would
consider a side hustle to save up this
down payment do you get some time on
your hands outside of your cobbling job
yeah I do and a part of my calling job
is also leather working oh my God I'm
trying to think of yeah I've been trying
to think of some like projects I could
do Jackson man you make some cool
leather goods and start selling them in
the neighborhood on Facebook on Etsy
you're gonna have that down payment
saved up in no time but I'd go start
researching the car you want get a
pre-purchase inspection regardless of
where you're buying it from by a good
mechanic and to make sure you're making
a wise decision there but I don't think
you really care about cars you care more
about your future and I respect that
Jackson oh I respect Jackson I love the
way his mind works more of the Ramsay
show coming up
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell co-host of this show of course
but also smart money happy hour with our
good friend Rachel Cruz you can check
that out on the Ramsey Network or
wherever you listen to podcasts Join
This Hour by Jade warshaw and we're
having a good time here at the Ramsey
Show taking your calls about life and
money triple eight eight two five five
two two five Paul is up next in NYC Paul
welcome to the show
hey guys thank you so much for taking my
call I'm actually a first-time caller a
long time listener I love it how can we
help
all right so um basically right now I'm
looking into
um basically making a timeline of when I
can move out of my parents house I mean
I'm not quite there yet but I'm
basically just making my uh early uh
steps in advance okay how old are you
31 okay so what's the plan looking like
so far
so I mean 2022 Was a Very Good Year for
me financially I actually was just going
through my uh my finance spreadsheets
and I actually finished out the year
with 81 000. that was my total year-end
Revenue cool and um I'm also uh I'm also
a music teacher as well uh teaching
course and general music and I do
private lessons on the sides okay for a
piano and drums and uh yeah it all
worked out really well for me last year
I'm also a student debt free as of
discount April excellent so uh yeah yeah
so uh having the new income coming with
my most recent teaching job really
helped out tremendously with that that's
cool as of now yeah as of now I have 42
000 uh saved up and I'm hoping by the
end of this year I could get past 80
000. okay is that and that's the goal
eighty thousand dollars saved
yeah at least and that's going to be
your down payment on I'm guessing
an apartment or what are you looking for
what are you looking for
I mean either house or condo I don't
know if I'm just gonna be comfortable
paying what like two grand or more in
rent and just having that are you
looking to live are you looking to live
in the city or are you looking in the
outskirts
uh no uh Long Island okay on my mind
okay so if you moved out today what
would your rent be
um he rented somewhere
yeah if I rented somewhere I mean
probably around where I live I mean
we'll probably be north of two grand
which I would definitely not be able to
swing now what's your take-home pay
uh take-home pay I guess each month is
probably gonna be around uh six grand
okay so if you could find something
that's could you find something for 1500
uh I mean it might be a bit of a stretch
I mean especially around here I mean
Long Island in particular
um but I mean I could start looking and
to see what comes up
I would start looking I think you know I
know that you want to get to 80k but
that sounds like it could take take a
stretch of time and I'd like for you to
make that timeline a little bit uh
Slimmer to get out of your parents house
I mean you're making 6K a month I don't
think there's any reason that you can't
support yourself and live on your own
um and if you stayed I would have clear
communication with parents going hey
here's my goal 12 months from now I'm
moving out my goal is to save this much
even if I have don't have all that saved
I'm moving out even if it means renting
somewhere because I think it'll give you
a lot of dignity and Independence that
you don't currently have and I know it's
a high cost of living area I mean it's
an insane situation over there I'm from
Boston so I totally get it that it's
it's a lot of money you need to save up
for that down payment and you looked at
condos in the area and see to see what
that's going to cost you to buy
yeah I just started looking at those I
mean if I'm looking let's say
we're between 300 500 Grand I mean
that's obviously very steep yeah but um
but yeah I've only recently just started
looking at that I haven't really like
tailored my searches on on the condos
lately yeah I'd start looking into that
and also you know how many hours I know
that you're kind of freelancing right
now you're into music how many hours a
week are you working is there a way that
you can pick up more lessons pick up
more you know teaching and and really
amp up your income even more so that you
can make this happen faster even
increase your hourly rate Yeah by a few
bucks
yeah I mean currently it's it's funny I
mean I'm at probably the busiest I've
ever been I have probably 30 students on
the side freelance but uh but my main
job is teaching in a public school so
that's already five days a week okay so
I've got all those going on at the same
time I'm working six days a week what is
the public school job pay
so that's around uh 67 000 per year okay
and my pride my private lessons account
for between
and that's an additional 20 to 25 Grand
a year that's good can I just ask you
how much are you charging hourly for
your lessons
so hourly it's around well it's it's
split up by half hour and I I teach at
two different places where it's um
um like around 15 or so per half hour so
we're a little over 30 an hour I can't
feel super cheap super cheap can I just
say this and can you teach me Paul oh my
goodness gracious I did lessons Paul I
did lessons for years my husband did
base lessons and keys lessons and I
taught piano and voice lessons and I
only did hour blocks and I charged a
dollar a minute so it was at least sixty
dollars and then after I had a certain
block of students which you have more
than I had I charged a hundred dollars
an hour
and if you're teaching music and you
know how to play music you know your
stuff you need to charge more money dude
tell me about this if you raised your
rates to 30 for a half hour you could do
half the work for the same amount of
money yeah
and no one about that exactly yeah the
only problem is it's within two places
like two separate businesses I'm not
teaching private lessons on my own
anymore uh I man I think that you can
Paul I think there's major opportunity
here and here's the thing I think that
when you get out of your parents house
there is a certain level of comfort and
security when you know you gotta play
you know you know you've got that place
right you know Mom and Dad I can just
pull in the driveway and it's there but
when you start having your own place and
you got to hit that rent I think that
that is going to motivate you in ways
that you never you're going to become so
more much more Innovative because
necessity is the mother of invention
when you need to get that money you need
to make that money you will start having
ideas and you will start making those
ideas happen because you have no choice
but to make those ideas happen so I
think Paul for you for your music
business for your lessons to take off I
actually think that getting out of your
parents house is going to be essential
for you and I hope that you make that
move sooner than later absolutely and I
love I mean apologies like a likable guy
yeah you're just rooting for politics
he's the main character and we want to
see Paul and uh by the way I want to see
him raise his prices George yes and this
is a great reminder that you don't get a
pass on math because you live in a high
cost of living area true that and so if
you want to live in New York City Long
Island Boston La you name it you gotta
make more in order to still hit your
money goals or you got to show up there
when you and with a whole bunch of money
which most people don't have yep yeah
look at the numbers here you know
getting a condo even for 300 Grand with
80 down that's still 2 200 bucks a month
almost yeah on that 15 year which is the
only mortgage we'd ever recommend you
have because the goal is to get out of
debt not be in it twice as long and he
might have to rent and that's all right
and keep saving do the side hustle for
one more year save up another 20 use all
the side hustle money yes in a savings
get to a hundred grand as a down payment
yes and I bet you this when Paul gets
out of Mama and Papa's uh house he might
meet himself a nice fine lady oh you
know what I'm saying that he I'm just
guessing I'm just guessing here George
because there's something to that dual
income like while marriage is great dual
income is also something that not a lot
of people talk about that's right having
the power of two incomes at your
disposal changes the game it changes
your money goals and we've seen the
numbers married couples just build
wealth quicker because you've got more
manpower they build wealth quicker and
it says that if they combine their
finances they are actually happier
they're more likely to stay together and
they build wealth four times faster
there you go if that's not a reason to
get married I don't know what is
marriage marriage has got a bad rap in
today's culture it has looked at very
negatively especially from the men
they're like well she's just going to
take me to the cleaners I'm like well no
wonder you're still single dude no one
wants to marry that guy with that
attitude yeah I'm con I I have to say
I'm honestly confused by that because I
have seen that when you are in a loving
relationship no addiction nothing crazy
going on right so there's no reason to
not combine the finances but when you do
combine them and you get out of debt
faster you build that wealth faster
it's a win-win amen hey more of your
calls coming up we want to hear from you
join the conversation at triple eight
eight two five five two two five this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we're a show that talks a lot about
Building Wealth and if you're wondering
Building Wealth in this economy are you
kidding me well we keep hearing that
question we get the confusion there's a
lot of noise out there a lot of
naysayers a lot of Hope Stealers and
there's some legitimacy right we've got
inflation and massive layoffs and Rising
interest rates and we want to give you
guys the answers you need and so we're
hitting the road and coming to a city
near you this spring with our Building
Wealth tour that's right Dave Ramsey and
our entire team of Ramsay personalities
will be doing a Building Wealth live
spring tour where we dig into all of
these hot topics and give you a proven
plan to build wealth and keep it yep
even in this economy and tickets are
selling real fast so don't miss your
chance to secure your spot today here's
where we're going come see us out on the
road Indianapolis February 16th Austin
Texas February 23rd Salt Lake City on
April 24th and Anaheim on May 2nd
tickets start at just 49 bucks or you
can get a four pack of tickets starting
at 175. so bring your friends it's going
to be a good time go to
ramseysolutions.com
events to reserve your seats now and
Jade you'll be joining us at a few of
those I will the first two dates that's
exciting you're gonna love it these
Crowds Are they are electric I love it I
love me an electric crowd can't wait for
that all right let's get to the phones
Corey joins us up next in Chicago Corey
welcome to the show
hey how's it going guys good doing good
how can we help
um I just want to First say I'm a big
fan of you guys in the Ramsey Show and I
just really appreciate you guys taking
my call oh thank you
um so I did have some uh Financial
advice I was hoping to get from you guys
um so I recently uh came acquired a
settlement uh from a car accident I was
in
um now it is a lot more money than I've
ever had before and I'm just trying to
get some advice on what to do with it
where to put it and what the you know
the first the first steps sure are you
okay
uh yeah I had um I had some surgeries uh
probably some future surgeries my doctor
said and we used to come I'm 30 right
now so
um you know possibly later down the road
they said uh I'll have to come uh I'll
probably end up having some are you able
to continue working or has it affected
the way you work yeah so yeah so I'm
finally back to work after the first
couple years was rough but I've been
back to work for now two to three years
now oh good I'm glad to hear that I'm
sorry that happened but I'm glad that
you're back to work and doing okay uh so
how much was the settlement
um so right now it should be between 175
and 225 okay
um yeah they're just doing their due
diligence and uh yeah it should be
between you also between that and all
okay do you have any debt or what's
going on with your financial situation
so we do have some debt
um I'll start first start with we have
about 15
um in credit card debt okay 15 000
credit card debt uh about 25 on both
cards okay um so we're almost done
paying them both off uh we also have
about 280 uh in the house okay
and that's pretty much it that's pretty
much it okay and do you have
um all right so I'm sure what's your
household income
uh so roughly we are just under a
hundred after taxes okay after tax okay
and you're both working
correct cool
yeah you know this money I think that
you can do a lot with it uh you're
definitely going to be able to get
yourself debt free when it pays out and
I think that from there on I would
definitely make sure that you know I
have the right people in place I think
that with this money you always want to
make sure you have the right tax
professionals helping you uh especially
because after that you're going to pay
off your debt you're going to put aside
some three to six months of savings
you're going to start investing and once
you start investing that's when you're
really going to want you know the help
of some tax advisors in your corner
investment Professionals in your corner
so that you can make the right choices
with this money
um yeah this is that's what I would do
with it what do you think George yeah
Corey do you have any other money in the
bank
uh I actually do not
um we don't we don't have a savings we
actually just started uh listening to
your Show recently and we became both
huge fans uh we really want to start you
know the baby steps uh we want to be
fully and actively engaged and I know
with you know the payments and the
credit cards and the car payments all
that was very tough uh but now we do
have a blessing uh to get us in the
right steps um and we're we're just
we're very committed to the plan and we
just want to attack attack
what's your mortgage payment every month
uh so we are currently paying about
21.50 okay
so here's here's what I would do in your
shoes number one obviously you want to
move very slowly with this amount of
money we're not gonna this is not a
shopping spree obviously this this money
was paid for with your injury and so we
want to use it wisely we don't know what
the medical future looks like for you
with these surgeries so we want to be
very wise and have a fully funded
emergency fund I would lean towards six
months if I'm in your shoes and so let's
say you let's lowball it and say you get
175 on this check
I would immediately pay off all of my
debt so get rid of the Consumer Debt the
credit card the car loans that's 40 000
worth about
yes and so that would leave you with
let's if it was 175 leaves you with 135
then we're going to set aside six months
of expenses you think 30k would be fair
for six months of expenses
uh yeah it's probably generous okay that
would then leave you with a hundred and
five thousand left over and that would
put you at baby step four five six and
Beyond and so maybe you fully fund Roth
IRAs for both of you
and that's 6500 piece so that's another
13 Grand gone and the rest you can start
attacking the mortgage with
okay that's uh that is a really good um
that's a really good step um because we
were looking into Roth IRAs
um because we don't really have too much
um you know experience both we come from
families that would pay check to
paycheck so
um you know I've never really been
accustomed to you know living a
household what we were continuously
saving
um so this is all kind of new for us
well and that's where having the right
people in your corner the right Pros who
you can trust is going to be so key like
Jade mentioned you need to be working
with the tax Pro and you need an
investing Pro and you need an insurance
Pro
and so I would go to ramseysolutions.com
you can click on Ramsay recommends and
connect with all of those uh in your
area in the Chicago area who can walk
with you through this and make sure that
we're maximizing this protecting
ourselves because there's also family to
worry about now they're going whoa Corey
just got a big payday and so you got to
be very cognizant of the people in your
life I wouldn't go telling people you
got a big settlement because it makes
you a Target
thank you and so
um I if you got a great shoulder a great
head on your shoulder I would just
really walk slowly with this other than
paying off the debt and getting a pile
of money in the bank I would move slowly
and do it when you feel like you're
ready and don't go spending you know
buying up nice cars and toys we gotta
protect our future and not only
medically but also I want you guys to
retire with dignity and this money can
help you guys do that in a big way
thank you and yeah like I said we're
very fully invested and I you know
wanted to get you know get on the Ramsey
plan uh before we even gotta got our
hands on this yeah Corey do you guys
have any kids
uh yes we do okay okay great and have
you guys actually gone through Financial
Peace University
uh unfortunately we just haven't had the
finances to do any of that okay well
let's get them a copy let's get him set
up with Financial Peace University I
think it'd be really great if you guys
go through that because I can tell you
do want to be really smart about this
and if you have that Foundation under
you you're going to know exactly what to
do those nine classes are really going
to set you up with step by step and it's
not just going to be the what it's going
to teach you why as well which I think
for you guys with this money that's
going to be really important because
you're in this for the long haul you got
baby step four investing the 15 uh baby
step five you're going to be able to
start putting away for your your kids
college and then on and on to baby step
six and seven so you guys have a really
great uh financial future in front of
you and like you said you know this this
accident you know it sucks but you got
this settlement and now it's kind of
setting you up for a better situation
here so like George said they were dealt
so let's just use it wisely and in
Financial Peace University the investing
lesson the Insurance Lesson is going to
leave you with so much confidence and
less confusion about my future and what
should I be doing and there's so many
voices out there and there's so many
options out there this filters it all
down and tells you exactly what you need
and we're rooting for you man call us
back if we can help it's nine lessons I
want you to do all nine lessons don't
stop after lesson one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show our scripture of
the day comes from Galatians 5 14.
for the whole law is fulfilled in one
word you shall love your neighbor as
yourself
the great Reverend Dr Martin Luther King
Jr once said Darkness cannot drive out
Darkness only light can do that hate
cannot drive out hate only love can do
that love it good stuff love that from
uh MLK there all right let's go to the
phones Jalen joins us in Tupelo
Mississippi Jalen welcome to the show
hey guys how you doing today doing good
how are you Jalen I'm doing good how can
we help
uh yeah so just a quick rundown
um I'm 23 years old I make about 50 000
a year and uh I'm trying to clean up a
big car mistake okay
um how big
uh 35 000 worth that's alone
yes okay
and what's the car worth
so the car is worth uh by Kelly Blue
Book is about 27.5 okay
you got any money in the bank
not much very little
uh three three thousand okay
uh is that your only debt
uh no I have about 4 000 in credit cards
okay
all right yeah we gotta get out of this
loan
if I'm you I'm definitely gonna get out
of that loan uh it's too much of your
income you know and I if I'm you in this
case it's worth you've got 8K in the
bank no no you've got 3K in the bank
so in this case I would honestly I would
sell it and I would take out a small
little you know go to a credit union and
take a small loan out for that 5K that
you're upside down and you know at that
point
it's worth it for you to get out of
thirty five thousand dollars of debt and
then you can take the money
you know from there we're going to try
to get a cash car after that
how does that sound to you that'll be my
next question I've already um looked at
uh the possibility of getting a loan and
I actually already have a loan I'm just
yet to sign the papers what do you mean
you have a loan what kind of loan is
this it's a consolidation loan no no no
you don't want that what are you trying
to consolidate you don't yeah what you
only have two two deals here
well the the cars I'm not going to get
27.5 for the car I've looked around at
the offers and I've been offered uh 25
26. from where I was the uh places like
uh just local dealer dealerships well
yeah you don't want you don't want to go
there I mean you need to do some
homework and Shop everywhere go private
party Craigslist AutoTrader Facebook
Marketplace hey don't don't do that
consolidation don't sign that
don't do that okay it's not helping you
all it is is moving around the Dead with
crappier terms and it's not going to get
you out of debt any faster
it'll just make you feel like you did
something yeah how many hours of work
are you working
um it varies I'm on salary so I just I
just work like five six days a week
okay I want you to work more because
what I want to do I want to get you out
of this debt and like I said for me it's
worth getting out of this out of this
car loan but you're going to need to
save up a little bit of money before you
can do that so I want you working so
hard bringing in as much cash as you can
because I want you keeping the 1K as
your starter emergency fund so that
gives you 2K that you may be able to put
towards your next car and I want you to
save up a little bit more money so that
you can get out of this 35k loan and
also be on your way to paying off that
other 4K that you have in debt
all right okay I understand yeah I think
you know it's overwhelming because
you're looking at this and it's like oh
my gosh I just made this huge mistake
and it's really easy to just like try to
jump into a solution that feels like
it's going to solve everything for you
instantly but let me tell you
consolidation that's it's really not the
way a lot of times you end up getting a
bigger interest rate on the on whatever
the consolidation is because it's based
on your credit score they're paying you
money you're paying them money to do
something that you can do yourself
they're not going to pay off the debt
for you you still got to pay the debt
off so what's what you know in this case
it's just not worth it for you at all
like I said
um if you if it takes for you to get a
small loan from a credit union just to
to bridge that gap between the 35k and
you know whatever you're able to sell it
for 25 you know 27 and a half it looks
like it's worth it to do that to get out
of it but I also want you to be able to
get into a cash car so let's work like
crazy man let's get another two three
four K saved up and let's get out of
this thing and let's get a cash card it
doesn't have to be great get yourself a
beater that gets you from point A to
point B do you have a long commute
uh actually I have a work vehicle oh
look dude you're holding out on us bro
can you use that for a while
not the job no okay
so what what do you use the work vehicle
for
uh just work
but to use it but you can't get to work
in it yeah I do okay so when do you use
the personal car just on the weekends
honestly I hate to say it but never
Jayla Jalen Jalen Jalen you are getting
rid of this car today because at this
point bro you just need a beater just
something to get you from a player I use
the Tupelo zip code I sorted low to high
yeah there's some great cars for four
five grand yes and so I'm taking the
person alone getting out of this thing
yes and using that money towards a used
car that you're never even gonna use so
there you go thanks for the call Jalen
Michelle is up next she is in Sydney
Australia wow Michelle what's up
hi guys
um okay I'm really nervous so it's all
right in 2010 in 2015 my husband bought
before we met my husband bought a house
for around 240 000
um fast forward to now are actually like
late last year
um we lose being long distance landlords
so uh we decided that we were going to
sell it got an agent had zero offers
between September and middle of December
and realize maybe we need to get a new
agent got a new agent she sounded really
good lots of experience
um of two weeks ago we got an offer on
the house that we listed for 375 on her
advice uh the offer was 335. so
obviously we were not that excited about
it we declined we said that our Lois is
360 that we would want to accept which
we've then since lower to 350 because
we're starting to get nervous
um and so I have I have a two-part
question when they made the offer of 335
it took them two weeks to come back with
a counter of 340. so we like didn't
really make much uh progress there and
when we kind of said we weren't excited
about that to the agent she wrote us a
really long email basically telling us
why we should accept it that that price
seems good for the house because of this
that needs to be done that needs to be
done and kind of like I don't know just
resigning to the fact that that's what
it's worth so we got on the phone with
her she was like well this person said
it's worth this much and people doing
walk-throughs are telling us it's too
expensive so I'm kind of thinking like
well you told us the price of 375 like
did we just set ourselves up for failure
so is this in Sydney is that like uh no
this is in England my husband's British
he bought the house there like seven
years ago okay
um have you guys seen that the comps in
the area I mean are you able to look at
what's going on and see how your
property measures up to the ones selling
around it
yeah so apparently like there was a comp
a few weeks ago that sold for 350 that
was like one bedroom less and didn't
need any work which the house we are
selling does need work and so what would
it cost for you guys to do the work or
do you think the amount that they're
lowering it by is is valid
you know is it 25 000 worth of work
you yeah it might cost that much well
you got two options either you guys fix
it up and so that you can price it
higher if you think you can fix it for
10 and it'll net you 25 that's probably
worth doing
that's such a hassle though it's just so
it is if you want more money for it and
people are going I don't want to deal
with it you don't want to deal with it
someone's got to deal with it and that's
the thing the Market's gonna speak I
remember when Sam and I were moving from
Florida here you know the realtor had
said oh we're going to be able to sell
your house for x amount of dollars and
we're like all excited but then as the
market spoke everybody was offering you
know twenty thousand thirty thousand
less than what he was saying and after a
while it was like okay this is reality
so we can either do more to it wasn't
worth it for us to do more to fix up the
house but when the market speaks it
speaks yeah that's tough I mean you can
get another opinion from another realtor
and say hey is this real or the comps
real or the the fix is real and then
make the decision from there but you
might have to just take less because
there's work to be done and ain't nobody
want to do it that's right this puts
this hour the Ramsay show in the books
my thanks to Jade warshaw my thanks
everyone in the booth and you America
until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
foreign
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]